hey there folks i just wanted to drop in
with a quick thought on the recent
reveal that john kent superman's son not
to be confused with conor kent that's
his other kid uh is going to be revealed
as bisexual in an upcoming comic that's
actually two and fairly rapid succession
for dc because tim drake currently read
robin formerly just one of the robins uh
has also recently been confirmed as
bisexual and both are going to be shown
dating men which is nice because a lot
of bisexual representation has been
women up to this point we can use more
male bisexuals in
just pop culture in general so i'm all
in favor of this i am however slightly
nervous because of one thing i just need
to get off my chest i'm really nervous
that in both cases
the love interests
for lack of a better way to put it
appear kind of disposable
they're characters who don't appear to
have ties really to the greater universe
outside of these specific characters and
historically that kind of setup is
usually for a love interest to
ultimately get killed
dc
don't do that
please